alors vous avez donné des chiffres sur
les universités qui sont bloquées dans
cette mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites 10 universités bloquées sur
200 ça veut dire que finalement la
situation n'est pas passion que ça alors
oui quelques dizaines que en quelques
dizaines il ne faut pas enfin compter
des campus par rapport à Total
d'université mais en tout cas on a vu
que il y a et il ne faut pas le je
dirais le balayer d'un revers de main
des blocages qui augmentent qui sont
aujourd'hui réels après c'est blocages
là il n'y a pas que des étudiants ça il
faut le dire aussi il n'y a pas que des
vrais blocages c'est-à-dire qui
empêchent l'accès aux établissements il
est aussi des réunions de débats des
réunions d'expression ou des réunions
avant d'aller manifester et je pense que
voilà je voudrais vraiment saluer le
travail et la gestion fait par les
présidents et avec l'aide des présidents
d'établissements sur ce dialogue de
concertation parce que au jour
d'aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas une augmentation forte au
niveau des violences sur les campus et
des blocages dans le sens de vraiment
empêcher les autres de pouvoir étudié
qu'est-ce que vous dites aux étudiants
qui se sont un petit peu mobilisés
davantage depuis quelques semaines dans
cette mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites notamment après l'utilisation
du 49-3 ils disent il y a un problème de
démocratie dans notre pays et le 49-3
n'est pas une réponse alors je pense que
aujourd'hui je dirais que s'il n'y avait
pas une expression des jeunes une
expression de la jeunesse pratiquement
je serai assez inquiète pour notre
démocratie donc les universités sont des
lieux de débat réels des lieux de
dialogue et je pense qu'on a une
jeunesse qui a besoin de dialoguer
besoin de concerter et besoins en fait
de comprendre la façon dont les choses
se passent dont peut-être que l'on a pas
assez finalement expliqué et expliquer
cette nécessité de la réforme et je
pense que les zones de débat et les
lieux d'université sont des lieux on
peut continuer ce débat je voudrais
aussi dire que c'est jeune qui débattent
qui se concertent etc ont des
préoccupations on l'a vu qui ne sont pas
uniquement la retraite plus que
effectivement il n'y a pas eu de
mobilisation de la jeunesse vraiment sur
le sujet de la retraite et ces jeunes
ont des préoccupations ou des demandes
qui sortent du champ de la retraite et
qui sont en particulier les conditions
de leurs études et les conditions de
travail et bien justement sur ce sujet
vous avez annoncé aujourd'hui un plan
pour améliorer les conditions de vie
étudiantes avec un investissement
supplémentaire de 500 millions d'euros
en période d'inflation on voit les
produits alimentaires vont continuer à
augmenter est-ce que ça va vraiment être
suffisant pour faire face à cette
précarité alors un demi milliard d'euros
mis sur la table en effet pour les
bourses étudiants les bourses étudiants
aujourd'hui c'est environ une
augmentation de l'enveloppe budgétaire
des bourses de 20% de d'augmentation
c'est une augmentation juste historique
et vous avez raison de prendre un petit
peu comme référence parce que c'est
important pour les étudiants l'inflation
sur l'alimentation cette inflation
aujourd'hui elle est forte une inflation
globale de 6%, mais sur l'alimentation
de plutôt 15 et on a une réponse à 20%
donc vous voyez je pense que on répond
et puis on pérennise le repas à 1 euro
tous les étudiants boursiers et tous les
étudiants précaires ce repas à un euro a
été introduit dans le mandat précédent
de ce gouvernement de cette majorité
présidentielle et aujourd'hui on inscrit
une pérennisation du tarif très social
pour les étudiants précaires en quelques
mots pour conclure est-ce que vous avez
un objectif chiffré pour faire baisser
cette précarité étudiante et ben je
pense que le premier objectif
aujourd'hui comme on l'avait annoncé
dans l'agenda qu'on avait annoncé c'est
ce 1000 milliards d'euros les 500
millions d'euros qu'on met sur la table
encore une fois c'est une augmentation
historique et je pense qu'ils vont
contribuer et on relance une deuxième
phase de concertation avec nos étudiants
avec une réforme des bourses qui
atterrira avant l'été
[Musique]